so the heading is continuity now our
function is continuous function FX
whatever kind of expression you like in
terms of X in continuous is I've given
you an informal definition already so
let's just review that it continuous is
this sounds really simple but in formal
definition the function has no breaks in
it if the function has their brain are
more complete way of saying that is the
function is continuous if you can draw
with it you can draw it without ever
lifting your pen flash pencil
[Music]
now I prefer another definition but it's
a bit circular I prefer to say
informally you know functions continuous
even has their breaks in it but a break
I want to break the technical is
discontinuity but that's just sort of
your circular definition of what
students use if it has the
discontinuities and what a kind of
things that we talked about you know
lots of functions which have
discontinuity 1 over X the hyperbola
looks like this you can't draw it
without lifting your pencil you have to
pencil at some point it has a
discontinuity at x equals 0 in that
break there okay so therefore it's not
continuous most of the functions that
we're used to dealing with like
parabolas and clearly two sided colors
are continuous but there are a small
number like this guy like say attain
graph which are not continuous right so
this is fine as an informal definition
but now we know what limits are and we
have all the notations our language
around it we can make a formal
definition so underneath this info one
that's right there are two closer
cutting you either we can talk about in
a formal way the first time is
continuity at a point continuity at a
point
[Music]
our function is continuous at a point if
and I'm going to write out two really
formal notation but personally we've
done it to make sense of what we're
going to say for some function f of X
this is true now this is clearly not a
dumb interview or easy to understand it
the first definition even a year six or
seven to degree like yeah I can draw
something and not the cut my pen is
continuous but this is a rigorous
definition why does it be you've got
your function f of X I should have
probably develop it a bunch of FX is
continuous it's continuous at a
particular point x equals a if when you
take that value a it might be free or 50
or negative 2 and if you put into the
function you get a value out and their
value is the same as if you look at what
is happening to the left of that value
and if you look at what's happening to
the right of that value so for instance
a really simple thing let's take a
parabola any old problem so this is or
dis me if that's dear to dis might be
something like this x squared minus 2x
okay this function is continuous at the
point x equals 1 I'll just say
example here's how I know if this is f
of X what B is f of 1 what's X equal to
1 minus 2 which is negative 1 now if you
think about what is happening to this
function to the left of negative side to
the left of 1 right
like 0.9 or 0.99 as you start to put
those in what is that limit approaching
the answer is you're approaching
negative 1 if you come from this side
right what have you come to the other
side from that positive side you will go
into approach negative 1 so in that
place and the values the first year and
the values approach here are identical
that's our definition out a formal
definition for continuity at a
particular point along with that I'll
rub this off because I want to add a
give me a bit along with that we have a
formal definition again for continuing
over an interval
what's an interval again yeah like it's
like a straight line so here the
straight line is refer to X values so
I'm going to say cotton you lean over
and interval T so I need to want to
start somewhere and has to end some so
for a double oven start at a and then I
might go all the way to be all this
means to be continuous flow really
interval in that the function is
continuous at every point
in other words if you want to say yeah
this guy which I rubbed on this guy in
continuous from not to follow I should
be able to take any number between nine
and five and applied this test to it and
it should work
every single one so this idea is pretty
simple but we can apply it to all kind
of functions like this one I just
mention okay our expert minus 2x you can
approach you can also use this to show
that a function is not continuous so if
they dove ligating before up here if I
said f of X equals 1 over X right are
you on one of the problems right for
starters you can't evaluate f of 0 right
which is where we said the discontinuity
1 f of 0 is undefined
so immediately you're stuck right you
could say it's equal to any of these
these because it's not equal to anything
itself right so immediately you trouble
but even the other qualifications the
other conditions you make trouble we've
seen this before the limit as X
approaches 0 from the positive side is
what's happening approaching 0 so this
sign of going up to positive is right
but from the other side the limit as X
approaches 0 from the left for below
that maybe you should it's not equal to
infinity is equal to negative infinity
right so therefore these two things here
are the two limits are not equal to each
other
so this is just another reason why there
is a discontinuity and if not occur to
your subjects service can mean access if
you were to tour now so what would an
example of us yeah sure
so an example would be sure that such as
such a function is not continuous
everywhere
welcome to use everywhere but there are
places where it is continuous right
where might be where might we choose an
interval where it continues you could be
a lot how about from one to two sure
what the - okay so what I would do is I
would say for one says X is less than 2
right I'm going to need to apply these
tests to values in this interval right
so I'm going to say yep I'll say one and
a half right one and a half is 3 or 2 so
this is going to 1 over 3 or 2 which is
2
[Music]
hi
[Music]
oh yeah it's still pretty early aren't
thing you can leave your stuff yeah
that's one of the truth so I'm going to
bail you out you I'm going to have to
show it that's the limit as X approaches
and this is a bit funny because as
you're about to see not much you really
say it keeps peeking up your side one of
the half of that one yes what is this
going to be well this is going to
approach one over its going to end up
into it because you can simply evaluate
it and there's nothing more you can
really say this is over three on two
this is also equal to two-thirds and
you're going to do all of these things
you can draw a graph to argue it as well
to show that whichever way you come from
you're going to still approach this one
values so I can say these people if this
equals this okay yep that's all you'd be
required show that this continues there
are more interesting places where it's
actually challenging to show you
continuity but they're things we haven't
covered yet
like for example piecewise functions
which should we kiss our surgeons enough
so this is kind of a cubic yard but it's
really not very hard to show like
there's no working request there's not
really working there's no manipulation
you have to do there you said to say I
know what it means I should have a minus
NP perhaps or a plus the matter cos it's
same I know I need to get all these
three things I made them all to be the
same that's all you really need to do so
you can stick all those things which I
should point out and not on the
reference sheet which should be when you
think about that other piece of envision
review maybe that would be easy to
include identify noticing things is
really what's going on
not like some complicated graph or
complicated calculation something like
that it's just do you know what that
means glue continues
Sitaram
yeah rotate into the beginning listicle
anyhow I'm going to stop there that's
all there is to this idea exercise 7i
which already asked you guys to do forks
and a limit in it just explore this idea
but pretty much that I did like shows it
something isn't continuous will show
that it is continuous all in that
machine